Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Filigrees are detailed, thin patterns typically
found in jewelry, fabrics and ornaments, and
as you may imagine, crafting such motifs on
objects is incredibly laborious.
This project is about leaving out the craftsmen
from the equation by choosing a set of target
filigree patterns and creating a complex shape
out of them that can be easily 3D printed.
The challenge lies in grouping and packing
up these patterns to fill a surface evenly.
We start out with a base model with a poor
structure, which is not completely random,
but as you can see, is quite a forlorn effort.
In several subsequent steps, we try to adjust
the positions and shapes of the filigree elements
to achieve more pleasing results.
The more pleasing results we define as one
that minimizes the amount of overlapping,
and maximizes the connectivity of the final
shape.
Sounds like an optimization problem from earlier.
And, that is exactly what it is.
Really cool, right?
The optimization procedure itself is far from
trivial, and the paper discusses possible
challenges and their solutions in detail.
For instance, the fact that we can also add
control fields to describe our vision regarding
the size and orientation of the filigree patterns
is an additional burden that the optimizer
has to deal with.
We can also specify the ratio of the different
input filigree elements that we'd like to
see added to the model.
The results are compared to previous work,
and the difference speaks for itself.
However, it's important to point out that
even this thing that we call previous work
was still published this year.
Talk about rapid progress in research!
Absolutely phenomenal work.
The evaluation and the execution of the solution,
as described in the paper is also second to
none.
Make sure to have a look.
And thank so much for taking the time to comment
on our earlier video about the complexity
of the series.
I'd like to assure you we read every single
comment and found a ton of super helpful feedback
there.
It seems to me that a vast majority of you
agree that a simple overlay text does the
job, and while it is there, it's even better
to make it clickable so it leads to a video
that explains the concept in a bit more detail
for the more curious minds out there.
I'll try to make sure that everything is available
in mobile as well.
You Fellow Scholars are the best and thanks
so much for everyone for leaving a comment.
Also, please let me know in the comments section
if you have found this episode to be understandable
or if there were any terms that you've never
heard of.
If everything was in order, that's also valuable
information, so make sure to leave a comment.
Thanks for watching, and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!